نحن نرحب بشركات السعوديه
وبالاستثمار السعودي في العراق بهذه
العبارات استقبل وزير الخارجيه العراقي
نظيره السعودي في بغداد في اول زياره
لمسؤول الرفيع المستوى من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بعد تشكيل حكومه السودان نعمل
معا لتخفيف حاله التواتر التوتر في
المنطقه
والسعوديه كدوله
ودوله قاعده
في الاطار الاسلامي
تلعب دورا مهما في هذا المجال والعراق
كدوله محوريه في هذه المنطقه
نعمل معا
لتخفيف هذه التوترات الموجوده في المنطقه
وحل المشاكل عن طريق السلميه وعن طريق
الحوار ملفات الامن والاقتصاد والطاقه
تصدرت اجنده اللقاءات علاقات ثنائيه
متميزه مع المملكه هكذا تصفها بغداد مع
تاكيد واضح من الجانبين على خفض التوتر في
المنطقه من خلال الحوار مع جميع الاطراف
ولا اعمل سويا
بتنسيق وثيق مع معاليكم لدفع عمليه
الاستقرار في المنطقه من خلال الحوار ومن
خلال
تعزيز المصالح المشتركه
معالجه اي اوجه خلاف وهذا مهم جدا لان لها
بدون الاقرار لن نستطيع ان نحقق الرخاء
الذي نسى اليه زياره الامير فيصل بن فرحان
الى بغداد شملت ايضا الرئاسات الثلاث
المتمثله برئيس الجمهوريه ورئيس البرلمان
اضافه الى رئيس الحكومه جرت تاكيد من
خلالها على تطوير الشراكه الثنائيه وتوسعه
الاجتماعات من خلال مجلس التنسيق العراقي
السعودي وحل المشاكل العالقه في المنطقه
من خلال الحوارات الثنائيه سامر الكبيسي
العربيه بغداد